chuckles oh [ __ ] screams well what a
picture we pay 1250 to watch your ass if
you're not gonna all the getting hides
and drinking the drugs and everything
else I did I showed up at the theater
every day and then when you go to soak
auditions and that doesn't happen you
say sir what I really need is one good
national beer commercial that's what I
need
he's a prolific actor and film producer
who's appeared in over 100 movie he
achieved prominence in the early 1990s
with films like Patriot Games Jurassic
Park and Pulp Fiction
these rands is the second highest
box-office star of all time with box
office earnings of almost 5 billion
dollars he's samuel l.jackson and here's
my take on his top 10 rules for success
rule number two is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the
way to the end become special bonus
clips and as always a Samuel says
something that really means helping to
you please leave it in the comments
below of put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
listen there's so much that you don't
know about what will happen to you if
you become an actor or you become famous
that you know all this is gravy
you know that's what it is but you're
still doing the work I mean this is not
yeah it's about to work it's not about
all the others the others a byproduct of
it now you can buy into the others and
and lose yourself in it and lose
yourself in the books people tell you
about yourself and about you know kind
of you do you know everything I do is
not great yeah good but it ain't great I
do good work in some movies I know that
that's happened I know what they are
they know what they are but people watch
them anyway because there's something
about them that made me want to do it I
enjoy myself doing it you just didn't
work out well but if you buy into all
this or you start boasting yourself
about what all this is then you can get
up in it I read everything being right
about me because I'm that kind of guy I
remember a lot of people that say bad
about me because I'm that kind of guy
I remediate I remember the people who
write good about me because I'm that
kind of guy we're in this business
because it's a look at me business and
if you say you don't do that you're a
liar you lie yourself you're lying to
the people who watch you even though
they go so far screaming what a picture
we pay 1250 to watch your answers you're
not gonna you know if you if you can't
watch it I damn sure don't want to watch
it I watch my movies I want to see
myself when I was on stage I always
wanted to see the play I was in with me
in it
this is the perfect venue for that hmm I
watched my family some of my watch over
and over again if I'm telling suffering
and nothing else's daughter eyepencil
movie I'm in I'm in I'm not watching it
because that's what it is it's a look at
me business and I got into it because I
enjoyed the fantasy of it I love
make-believe I love movies I love
entertaining people that's what we do I
kept going I had a path and
my path was my path was to become what I
am right now now I lost sight of it in
an interesting sort of way or I I went
about it in a wayward path but
fortunately for me all all the all the
getting hides and drinking the drugs and
everything else I did I showed up at the
theater every day I did plays ripped out
of my mind I rehearsed ripped out of my
mind but every lesson that I learned I
held on to for some reason God whatever
somebody let me hold on to everything
that I was learning my stage left my
stage rights my upstage foot always out
turn down this way learning how to
develop a character doing all those
things because those are things that I
love and I did them in the midst of
everything else that I was doing - you
know when when my friends were getting
ready to go get some more drugs oh no I
got a bit too theater and I'll catch
y'all on theatres though you know when
I'm done and I just jacked oh I got to
go build a set I got to do this so I did
everything that I had to do so I was
focused on this by any means necessary
plus I had a professor who was like you
know well you know all the great ones do
their jobs and ripped out of their minds
you know you look at the bureau tools
instead of the yeah so they get dropped
and they get hired they do what they do
but they show up and they do the job so
we were like okay and that's what we did
you know we drank with him and we went
to style back in class we got smoked
drinking come in and do our other acting
classes we'll go build a set on a built
in costume things like all the things
that we had to do so I kept learning my
lesson and doing them how often do you
find when you get on set people are like
do the Samuel do the Sam Jackson thing
do the samuel l.jackson thing that we
know and love
not often yeah I don't know what that is
I mean
unless you say like eight times and you
know well crap to play but um I mean I
don't I don't really know what that is
or to me the Sam Jackson thing is I've
I've read the script you know I don't
know how many times and I've broken my
character down the way I learned to
break a character down in the theater if
they're sorts of material like for
George Washington Williams I'll go to
the source material and deal with that
but if not then okay it's up to me to
figure out who this guy is I can figure
out when he was born who his parents
were what his educational background is
military if he has that what kind of
life experiences he's had how he feels
about this that or the other even down
sometimes to what kind of food eat you
know just because they're eating scenes
in the movie and I want to figure out
what I want to eat when I'm you know in
that particular scene and then from
seeing the scene what my relationship is
with those characters or what I'm trying
to accomplish in this scene that leads
to the next thing that leads to the next
scene that leads to the next thing so
what happens is the Sam Jackson thing
for me according to my agents and
managers is I'm so prepared when I show
up that I expect everybody else to be as
prepared as I am so when the director
does not have a shot list for that day
or director's floundering and trying to
figure out what he's doing he can ask me
and I can tell him you know because one
of funny things about movies is the
director is usually the person on the
film set there's got the least amount of
experience of everybody there
the director a director makes one movie
every four years every two years yeah
and I'm a regular Saturday is what a
good directors Chris 15 movies you know
everybody has done 15 movies the last
two years you know so we all know you
know since you've met any gonna be in
the movie you know like you don't really
need to shower granted yeah so there's
there's actually go what about that
grace from know that was amazing what
are you doing okay I read somewhere but
I show up prepared so that immediately
I'm Jackson thing when you hire me you
had an actor who's going to show up
we're going to know his lands gonna hit
his marks and do his best to make the
other actors around him better
absolutely I'm not going to call shots
for you and I don't expect you to give
me a line reading and if you do you had
the rum wear yellow actors have
aspirations and you look at movies and
you look at television and especially
every year the Academy Award Show comes
around and you sit there and you say I
really would love to be there what do I
have to do to get to that point you
stand in the mirror you do your you you
do your great acceptance speech and all
the things I would say if I was up there
who I would think and as you keep
working I often tell people this know
that what happened to me was I actually
kept working to the point where I
started to do better place and different
kinds of directors that I came into
contact with and other actors and
interacting with him and the craft
became a lot more important but there
were times when I stopped wanting to be
a movie star and I say well okay I can
oh I can do a TV series sure I can do a
sitcom and then when you audition for a
few seconds you don't get that job you
say yourself okay uh I can just so yeah
yeah I just signed a two-year contract
or so for a while and then when you go
to L so partitions and that doesn't
happen you say to yourself what I really
need is one good national beer
commercial that's what I need a good
national beer commercial do I can get
those checks coming every week and I
keep my theater how's it going
but when all this stuff doesn't happen
and you continue to work at your craft
and you do theater and you work with
August Wilson's and the lawyer Richards
and the Douglas Channel Ward's of the
world and the Charles Fuller's you
develop a way of working and your craft
becomes just one of those great
satisfying things that you go to the
theater every night you have a different
audience and people are sitting there
and you can feel the the sharing of
energy being between you and them
they're giving you something you're
giving them something and at the end
every night there's a great reward that
it is long and you're very satisfied
with that and once you let go of all
those dreams and aspirations and let
your respect for what you do become the
most important thing the other things
start to happen that was the point when
I went to auditions like everybody else
no matter what the movie was because I
wanted to be in the movies and I wanted
to go to work and I had no choice going
to work was the option so generally I
didn't see the script anyway they gave
you eight pages aside what themes in
them and you might have got the script
later after you've got the job they give
you the script you know and I can look
through and see what page that died on
and that was it
but when you're out of the audition
process and you're sitting at home and
you're making choices then you should
make choices that are satisfying to you
in some way and not monetarily right
they should be satisfying to you
artistically they they should appeal to
you as an actor or as an audience member
or as a person who wants to make people
excited when they come to the movie and
so you do this you know it shouldn't be
based on you know all that other you
know both the belt you know this is who
they think I am
so I have I become this kind of actor
and people appreciate me for this this
is one thing I still like about Jim
Carrey everybody wanted to go watch and
Carrie laughs you know and be funny but
ya try to always such you know sometimes
it works sometimes it didn't but he
wasn't gonna be painted in it into that
corner try that
you're not gonna I'm not just just going
to do comedies you know I don't have to
be the Three Stooges I don't have to be
you know WC Fields I don't have to be
Chaplin I don't have to be you know a
name I don't have to be John Wayne I can
be all these other things and I want to
try and be them and he made an effort to
be that and when I came into this
business from the theater I didn't do
the same kind of play all the time and
it all kind of plays that on there the
characters and this is a bigger venue
for doing that they get better makeup
artist they get better script they put
you in the environment you have to
convince somebody you're in the
environment it's there they put you in
it so why not do as many different
things as you're capable of doing and
that was my my thought I want to do as
wide a variety of genres of film as I
can just to you know continue to see if
I can stretch myself as an actor but
then I was in the dialog office one day
and there's a sign on the on the on the
wall that I adhere to demon Ranaut I
said be careful of the toes you step on
today but they could be connected to the
ass you'll have to kiss tomorrow and
believe me they've been pas and other
people like when I'm on a movie set I
think everybody is just as important as
I am or I treat them that way so I know
piays names I talked to him I speak to
him every day I speak to the gaffer's I
speak to the grips I speak to all these
people and over the years I've gotten
jobs and the producer will show up and
he'll be like you don't remember me but
I was a PA on our songs own son you were
so nice to me that you know I was doing
this movie I couldn't help but think you
know you would be the perfect and that
[ __ ] works out you know or they become
writers so they become directors you
know but it's a collaborative effort I
mean we're we're almost the least
important element of any film because if
they putting the lights up right or the
soundman mic is jacked up it'll mean
about what you're doing like that nobody
can see you or hear you you know so they
can fix that in the mix you know but
everything else has got to work and you
have to know that I dreamed about being
an actor
a very long time why I was fooling
myself thinking I wanted to be an
oceanographer I'll never know I always
always thought I wanted to be the black
Jacques Cousteau I just wanted to hang
out in the world
I always thought inner space was much
more exciting than outer space so I
figured I'd go underwater and hang out I
like to dive and do stuff like that but
I've loved movies since I was a kid I
spent a lot of my time in the movies
when I was a kid and I watched a lot of
movies I still spend an inordinate
amount of my time watching movies I
collect Asian films so I watch a lot of
Chinese Japanese Thai Korean Koreans
making really great films these days
Indonesian films I just like Asian film
it's more visual and it stimulates me in
another way but I grew up watching
movies and imagining myself on screen so
aside from the very serious things that
I do I will occasionally do snakes on a
plane because those are the kind of
movies I like when I was a kid I always
wanted to see myself in a movie with a
bunch of snakes and I'm still trying to
find the right you know slasher movie to
do because I like slasher movies and I'm
still you know I did things like deep
blue sea because I wanted to run from
something that had big teeth and however
so I'm not that serious about it you
know I really think movies should be fun
and I think they should be entertaining
if I want to teach you something I'll do
a documentary but I do this because it
feeds me it feeds my artistic sense a
lot of people think I do too many movies
I read an article in paper yesterday
about me doing too many movies but I
mean you know writers get up and write
every day
painters get up and paint every day
actors only have so many acting
opportunities on a lifetime I'm going to
take mine as they come and do as many
movies as I can before them up out of
here so something like Avengers it
seemed like you were having a great time
I am NOT a great not a huge acting
challenge for you I imagine but I depend
we seem to be having fun what fun is
important this should be a fun job it's
make-believe if you and your friends
with real costumes and
Gunz is doing the thing you know
exciting people it's that's what that's
about when you're doing something like
The Avengers you got to take it
seriously and in in terms of you believe
the space you're in you believe the
world and the convention of it that
there are people who can do greater than
normal human beings can do trust that go
with it
treat them like they're those kinds of
people and they have an element of
danger and an element of awe that comes
with all that that's the honesty of the
world but you know I'm [ __ ] Nick Fury
I got some with me too so I can be you
know boom I can stand up to him and say
what I need to say and sometimes like in
the Avengers I need to manipulate these
people I got to where I am because I'm
Nick Fury I can do something with me
nobody knows how old I am or why I'm
still still alive or why I'm now black
but I used to be white you know so I got
me to know you could you accept that and
you go with it and you treat it like a
summer honest and you treat it like you
something real so that when people come
and see it they don't see you going you
know I'm in it I'm in it is some
dangerous happening and you can help us
fix that so let's go get them looks like
you and your friends doing that when you
were kids let's go get him go get her
yeah and then your shooter they can't
say you missed because the chest blow up
and all that kind of great goes on I
just happened to do a British talk show
and this guy has a there were any
directors that never worked with that I
wanted to work with and I realized
George was about to start Star Wars I
said I'd love to work with George Lucas
and somebody that worked for him told
him because they were doing
pre-production in London and I left and
I went to San Francisco and I was doing
sphere I didn't know the Napa Valley
somewhere and I got a call I said George
wants to meet with you if you're really
serious about being in Star Wars it's
like great so he's got a car I went over
to the ranch and I met with him and you
know he's like you know I've seen a
couple things you're in but I don't
really you know I'm like well you don't
have to no it's okay you know I just
want to be in the mood
evening like well I don't know what I'm
like look I'll be a stormtrooper I just
want to run properly nobody needs to
know him in this movie but me you know I
will run throughout the screen with a
white helmet army how would have been
happy because I just wanted to be in the
Star Wars movie you were a Jedi Knight
no I had no idea until they call I left
their joint space no you know I mean
they got a couple things I got some
palace guard stuff you know maybe with
blue well we'll find something and I was
like okay great so I went off and it was
like three months later I was done with
sphere and I was ready to do something
else I got to call it said George want
you to come to London can you come to
London now sure general plane I go
London I get to studio they take me to
this dressing room and mind you I still
haven't seen a script I don't see
anything but you already were willing to
do out here's nothing not in care you
collect like little figurines right yeah
so is that what you're angling for is I
want I want to be a Star Wars on hearing
I just wanted to be in Star Wars yeah
you know understand when i sat there saw
that movie for the first time all
sickness in myself how in the hell'd you
get in something like that yeah what do
you have to do and then you know another
movie like die hard my friend Reginald
village that caught this outside he'd
know that so how'd it Reggie get that
job so there are certain things that you
watch that you just want to do so when I
got there and I was in in my dressing
room or what they said was my dressing
room they go well somebody would be up
here to help you put on your costume in
a minute you have a fitting and cool so
I wonder whose dressing room this is
because I've see some boots and I see oh
looks like a Jedi robe I must be in
somebody's room then somebody came in it
gave me two three pages and gonna busier
lines and I want mace windu Hill is that
you know and it just makes when do your
mace windu Yoda mace windu Yoda I know
I'm not Yoda
we all didn't know who this guy was and
then they came in you know I put on the
boots and they start putting stuff on me
I'm like so I'm a Jedi anyway well yeah
all right Wow and I'm having a
conversation with Yoda so I guess I
won't be edited out of the movie so I
won't be just running from screen and
then the guy came in with the
Halliburton and he's like pick your
lightsaber handle now I can't even tell
you what I really did I just I really
just felt like and that was I was like
oh my god well that one so that's when I
knew I was a Jetta and it was AI think
there'd be a little ceremony where you'd
be I didn't know what was going to
happen at that point all I knew was I
was a Jedi I had my light flavor they
told me to go in this room I met Frank
Oz and all these guys cuz Yoda was still
a puppet man right so I had to rehearse
with these guys for like hours and hours
while he did ears and iron and Yoda
stuffing
I was very cool with all that but I made
it my man in a play okay so I just got
to be cool and not your George any grief
be quiet stay out of the way and see how
long I hang around don't let him kill me
don't kill don't and that's what I did
in the first of all yes set in the chair
no you know everybody's having
lightsaber battles I wanted to like mmm
let it go let it go I'm fine
you'll get two and I made it through the
person so the second one answering sent
me a script and I'm reading it and I see
oh wow
that's a huge huge battle thing in this
arena and I'm in it but it's like we
call Jedi's from all over the galaxy to
fighting this arena I'm like oh hell am
I going to find myself and all this big
old thing
George you think I could have like a
purple lightsaber no Sam then maybe the
red or the green but I'm you know on the
second baddest get eye in the universe
and I've been around for a while you
know and purple a bit amenable could be
like kind of kind of dope when he said
it
let me think about it I didn't bother I
go away we shoot the movie in Australia
then we do reshoots in London no I got
something to show you
man he pulls it up and sure enough
purple lightsaber uh-oh
but Georgia still you know Georgia still
in that space where I don't know who
only to keep that though because somehow
we got leaked on the net that causing
this big storm I'm like really
I wonder who leaked that and eventually
I got to keep it Clint
I just really you know only because I
was banished I'm trying to find myself
in a big old fight in the middle of the
arena
nowhere is it totally worth only word I
know where I am and that big old fight
but you know George is great like that
George George like me I like George and
it all worked out and he finally told me
to well you know you're going to die in
episode 3 alright why as well I've
already done it was so four five and six
and you're not in
and you're the only significant
character that I can kill that will make
a difference that moves the story along
I want to happy about it's like what can
I just like get my hand cut off and fall
out the window and not really be dead
well that would mean you have to wake up
episode 7 to come back to be able to see
something but I'm ok with that
I had my moment it was great - Lucas
give it in the Lucas takeaway
yeah but you know it's the yeah good run
it's like a gift that keeps on giving
they just they just rerelease what all
that stuff on blu-ray stuff so I got
another check I'm good idea what he
working for Marvel the Superbowl
commercial did you get a lot of reaction
that Super Bowl commercial what's over
blow commercial oh you know what Ivan -
eh wait you're you're as crazy as the
people on Twitter right I'm not lying
Chris Crary oh I know that was my fault
all I would say you know what we don't
all look alike
plus you're already all black and famous
you argue all the time
I guilt owned by Isis I am guilty
thought you were Bob Dylan right yep
you're the entertainment report I know
I'm an attainment reporting for this
business life you don't know the
difference between a husband - my
mistake I apologize really my big
mistake let's talk about a very short
line for your job I'll say I did know
probably would not be hard to get
another person to sit right here let's
talk about Robocop oh hell no really oh
really oh my I apologize by the other
guy but I'm the other guy
yeah another one what's in your wallet
right
right oh the more than one black guy
doing a commercial no question about
that
what's in your wallet black guy okay
he's the car black guy there it is
Morgan Freeman is the other credit card
Oh all your boys done so he probably
won't confuse him with burn I had an
interview I was doing an interview in
New York almost 20 years ago and woman
from Texas came up and interrupted the
interview I don't mean to bother you but
I can can I have your autograph mr.
Jackson and so I gave her
I wrote you know a lot Sam Jackson yeah
and so Sam and I have this running gag
about it and you know it's like you know
once upon a time people used to confuse
Al Pacino and Dustin Hoffman it's not a
bad problem at all no I mean obviously
imagine your work in the matrix much
prepared you for that kind of action not
underlined not think of that you know I
watched that movie the other night I
have no idea why people think we're even
remotely you know it is cuz you're both
cool people cycles I thought it was just
a tall and black bear thank you very
much appreciate your time
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I made this video
because Dimitri George F asked me to so
if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you are made of profile next leave it
down the comments below I will see what
I can do I also love to know which of
the top ten rules the biggest impact on
you and why what did you learn from this
what are you going to apply to your
business or your life leave in the
comments I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Morelle I hope I pronounced
that okay thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book it really really
really means a lot to me so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love guys I'll see you soon
I didn't get your name I got yours
Vincent right but I never got my name's
bit new I ain't talking your way out of
it I just want you to know how I just
want you to know how summary we are that
things got so up with us in mr. Wallace
we got into this thing with the best
intentions really I never oh I'm sorry
did I break your concentration I didn't
mean to do that
please continue you were saying
something about best intentions what's
the matter oh you were finished oh well
allow me to retort
what does Marsellus Wallace look like
what what country are you from what what
why no country I ever heard up let's be
generous in what what English do you
speak it yes then you know what I'm
saying
describe what Marsellus Wallace looks
like but what I want to do say what
again I dare you I double dare you say
what one more goddamn fact black dawn
he's bald does he look like a [ __ ] what
does he look like a [ __ ] oh then why
you turn like a [ __ ] ripped it yes you
did
yes you did Breck you tried to be myself
Wallace don't like to be by anybody
except mrs. Wallace you read the Bible
on it yes well there's this passage I
got never had so this is Katie
Ezekiel 25:17 the path of the righteous
man is beset on all sides by the
inequities of the selfish and the
tyranny of evil me blessed is he who in
the name of charity and good
we'll separates the weak through the
valley of darkness for he is truly his
brother's keeper and the finder of lost
children and I will strike down upon
thee with great vengeance and furious
anger those who attempt to poison and
destroy my brothers and you will know my
name is the law when I lay my vengeance
upon thee would you like to come back
and relaxed but let me give you some
fight never say no to a hostage taker
it's in the manual now are you gonna
tell me no again no no wrong answer
really no cab you learn poly never use
no don't won't or can't all right it
eliminates options the only option that
leads is to shoot someone understand Hey
yes good yes good you say no again I'll
kill somebody all right now let's
practice can I see a priest all right
let's not you know what can we can we
just like sonica talk we are talking now
can I see a priest
ah I'll see what I can do that's good
Farley now you're learning now I'd like
a submachine gun so I can blow everyone
away
oh look into that good doing dark Farley
you ever cheat on your wife Farley no
watch yourself
I'll kill someone you ever cheat on your
wife answer Oh see what I can do think
about that um I'll look into that you
ever um dress up like a schoolgirl get
your ass Bank barley Danny look okay all
I want to do is just talk to you I'm
talking now did you or did you not ever
get up like a schoolgirl and get your
ass spanked have to look into that Danny
- Farley you know nothing against you
dressing up like a little girl
again you know this is really really
unproductive out there you're right it
is so tell me a joke probably you know
any jokes no no you just told someone
their life Farley game over
you can't talk me down you can't make me
change the deadline now getting me
Sabian you got six minutes 42 41 by the
way anybody hurt we're okay
just don't be singing now no one I just
have one more thing crew did you have to
repeat your orders to captain Lee sorry
you ordered captain Lee to engage
hostile targets and he advised you that
there were women and children in the
line of fire is that correct well he
couldn't see yes or no colonel
did he follow your first set of orders I
don't remember captain Lee is on record
as saying he hesitated and mentioned the
snipers in the buildings is his
testimony accurate I don't remember
let me get this straight you evacuate
the Ambassador you go back to the roof
two of the Marines are ki a 1/3 sergeant
Kravitz dies you give you captain an
order which he doesn't follow in fact in
questions and then you said what I don't
remember you don't remember what you
said next
it was combat not some training a moment
lady your men was shooting what did you
say to make that happen I don't know you
must have said something captain Lee
reversed himself what did you say I
don't know the exact words let me help
you your honor
you said waste them didn't you no no no
didn't say it well it all happened so
fast
they're under oath colonel let me
refresh your memory
this is exhibit q a tape recording made
aboard the USS Wake Island of all radio
communications received that day
including your exact words your honor
with your permission I would like to
play this tape well you got it on tape
then that's what I said they were
killing my Marines so yeah
wait them please the objection overruled
yes these objection yes
thus objection overruled
yes are these them did you want to be
wasted your honor
major yes your honor the crowd in front
of the embassy had no weapons did they
colonel objection we've got no snipers
weapons either yes they had weapons you
think there's a script for fighting a
war without pissing somebody off follow
the rules and nobody gets hurt
yes innocent people probably die
innocent people always die but I did not
exceed my or there are rules and Marines
are sworn to uphold now I'm not going to
stand by and see another Marines die
just a limp Idol through curl